comunidad internacional reacciona tras
la filtración de documentos clasificados
de Estados Unidos Corea del Sur dice que
exigirá respuestas por el posible
espionaje las autoridades surcoreanas
están preocupadas por la posibilidad de
que proyectiles de artillería vendidos a
Estados Unidos acaben en Ucrania en
contra de su política de no suministrar
armas a países en guerra lamentamos
profundamente que la principal agencia
de inteligencia estadounidense haya
estado espiando ilegalmente aliados como
nuestro país exigimos enérgicamente una
investigación exhaustiva e instamos a
que no se produzcan incidentes similares
el kremlin también reaccionó y a través
de su portavoz dijo que las filtraciones
serán analizadas ampliamente
eso no puede ser excluido vimos que las
filtraciones son bastante interesantes
el hecho de que Estados Unidos haya
comenzado hace mucho a desviar varios
jefes de estado especialmente en las
capitales europeas ha aparecido de
manera repetida el conjunto de
documentos filtrados con fecha de
febrero pasado incluye una evaluación
del pentágono según la cual las reservas
de misiles de Ucrania estarían casi
agotadas a principios del mes próximo y
que las defensas diseñadas para proteger
a las tropas en la línea del frente se
reducirán por completo el 23 de mayo los
funcionarios estadounidenses temen que
esto permita a Moscú cambiar el curso de
la guerra en Ucrania llevando sus
aviones de combate a atacar posiciones y
objetivos ucranianos sobre el terreno
aunque kiev no se ha referido
directamente a las filtraciones está
instando a los aliados occidentales a
que continúen con las entregas de armas